PRESENY
CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
WYICLISESCALATING
TAE, ALSO INSTER
ATEST?
>>epr: THINK A LOT
WOULD BE SPARED
HE BOMBARDMENT
CAROO
POLAND ANDERCOUNTRIES, BUT WHAT
STORY.
CNN SPOKE WITHN EYEWITNESS
LEAST, MASSIVE MISSILE STRIKES 0
.
UNT OFAS A BASE
WERE COITHALLED RNLEGIONOR PEOP
WHO WERETITOCOME WITH UKRAINIAN
FORCES AGAINANON.BREAKDOWN YE E
AS WELL AS UKRAINIANS.NALS
I THIN IS LARGEST
THMAM NUMBER OCASUALTIES ATTACKT
BOAR SEEING T THE ON
TODAY.
ATPEOPLEIL
CITY OF MICK LIVE.
BEEN KILD .L KYIV ORITIES, THE
ANOTHER AMERICAN JALT WHO  T IN.
THE NORTHWEST WHERE MENDY  COLL.
DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS OF IT.
OF COURSE, A GET
TION, WE WILL LET
YOU KNE MORE TNGPORTANT DD HEAR
VOLODYMYR ZETODAY SA TDESPERATEL
HUMANITARIAN AID INTO MAUP
THATGED SOUTHEASTERN P
TY MILLION PPLHEE COOYWO HOURS,R
FIRE TOMW PREVIOUSLY, THOUGHSSIS
THE SITUATION THERE ABSOLUTELY
DESPERATE, DANA.
ME OF THES TRYO
GET AIT  FER
>> CLARISSA, THANK YOUMUCH FOR .
NEEDLESS TO SAY, PLEASE, P SAFE.
THANK YOU.
>>> HERE WITH ME
ECURITY
ADVISER JAKE SLIVAN.
AKE, I WANT TARN THG ARISSA WAS
WH DL YOSIDE OF UKRAINE,S FROM E
HA WELL,IR FIS STRIKE COMINGSO ?
WARNINGCE W
FEBRUARY HANSASION INVOLVED RU
ATTACKING ALL OVER UKRAINE,
SOUTHERN, E.
WHAT IT SH THAPUTIN  TA SULLIGES
THKIF PROGRESS THAT HE
THOUGHT THAT THE AINST MAJOR CI
KYIVS EX
CAUSE DAMAY PART OF HED HE'S TR
TH
WHAT PRESIDENT BAS MADE
CLEAR FROM THE BEGINNING IS WEW
TOILITARANCE Y EVEN AS WE SEEK
TO THE UKRAINIAN FO AVELR
D BRY DEFENDING
THEIR CITIES.
>> LET'S TALK ABOU
R DIPLOMAC.
VLAD PUT T
NCIDENTS FORMORE THAN  HOU
ISRAELI IME MINISTER TELLINKYA N
TMATIC
IN SIGELL, WE HAVESE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPOKE WITH
PRT ZELENSKYY A COUPLE GO.
HE SPEAKS TO HIM ON A
NGOING COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
D
RUSSIAN S.
THAT'S THE NEGOTIATION THAT TTE.
IT IS UAIT
HAV MAKS OW
SOVEREIGN DECISIABE
SHAP ANY DIPLOMACY GNGOMHESTATES
PERSPEIVE,E'E TO STAY IN TOUCH
PLAYERS,S ME,
OTHERS, BUT ULMA
UKRAINIANS.
AS THINGS STT NO
S NOT LOOK
LIKE T, SL CONTUE
TOE THE RE AIN
HIM AND CONTINUE TT S THEY FIGH
DEFEND THEIR TERRITORY.
>>CKSOTHD CLARISSA WHICH IS THA
UKRAINE.E ANATION
JUST HAD THE HAT IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAOUT IT AS
I WA OI WILL
O  MCOLLEAGUES AND W
THE GROUNDLEAR ABOUT PENED.
IF, IN FACT, AN AMERICANT IS  A.
IT IS ONE MORE EXAMPTHE
BRUTALITY OFANHIFORCES, ISARD
SCHOOLS, MOSQUES AND HOSPITALS
AND ND IT IS WHY
WE'RE WORKINSOD TOE
HIM AND
TO TRY TO HENIANS
WITH EVERY FORM OF MILITARY
ASSISTANCE TO BE
ABLE BACK AGAINST TH
THESE
FORC LET'S TALK  A
POOR THAICULARLY MILITARILY.
THIS WEEK THE U.S. REJHAT WOULD
FIGHTER JE TO UKRAINE, BUT DO
GH A. MILITA BASE.
TH, AS YWAS CONCERNETHHA
RCEIVED AS ACALATION B
THE U.S.RUSSIA.
MEMBERS OF YOUR OWN PARTY E
URGING THE U.S. TOT ANOTHER
WAY TO GETKR THESE PLANES,
ORULUT
>> WELL, T PRESIDENT LISTE
TO THE ASSESSMENT OF HISMUNITY.
HE LISTENED DVICE OF HISLITARY
TH HIS NAT UE RISK-BENEFIT AS O
UKRAINE DID NOT MA S
NOT SOMETHING THATE
AUTHORIZD TALK TO PRESIDENT T OI
SO WE WORKINON TT
UKRAINIANS MAKE PROGRESS IN TEHT
COMING FM
FROM THE RUSSIANID AREORN THAT
LOSE DITIR ALLIES.
ASYSTEMS, DOES THATE --AT YOUJ
UKRAINE THROUGH THE T R PLANES A
YOU'ORKING OLENSKYY BECAT HE'S
OUR NOW IIR SYSTEMS AS WELL AS
OTHER FORM ASSISTANCE.
M NOT SUF YORE
TO OTHERT I KN AR S THAT I D
T NOW WE'RE NOT LOOKING OV
THE UKRAINIAN S AP UKRAINE. LOE
TO BE ABLE TO BLUNE INAN>> JE, E
SUPPLY CONVOYS ARE SAFE?
UNITED STATES, OUR
LIARHE
UKRAINIANS HAVSEM
COINBLE TO FLO
AS TO THE TARY
FRT LINES TO HELP THUKRAINIANS
T THEM AS SAFE CONVORE H A WAR.
ANIN TO BE ABLE  HAVE ME
TO THE RAINIANS VER
Y EFFECTIVELY AIE N
FORCES.
>> THE U.S. SAID THIS WEEK
RUSSIA HAS THER A
ICPON N
UKRAINE.DENT SDAY
SERIOUSLOUDO.AVE TO THINK
WOUL MOR
IF RUSSIA
USL WEAPS IN
UKRAINE?
FIRSTDANA, IT IS  LEGITIMATE CL
WEAPONS IN UKRAINE.
THEY'RE RIGHT NOHE
TH
OF PALLY USI CHEMICAL OR
BIICTELL.
ON'S A TELL THATY,THEMSELVES, M
THAT'S A CLA PE OUT OF THE
RUSSIAN PLAYBOOK.
AS THE PRESIDENT SAID ON FRIDAY,
IFUSUSE CHEMICAL
A SEVERE PRICE.ULD
I'LL LEAVET T TODA